hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome to today's video you know
today is uh Wednesday January 18th 2023
and it was very uh fascinating day in
the market starting from uh Tuesday
night uh into today Wednesday and you
know we had Bank of Japan we had some
numbers here in the US and you know Bank
of Japan kept the monetary policy the
same uh stocks you know went back up if
you remember yesterday
okay we you know we trade all the way up
here to uh was that 35 and a quarter
um then overnight we sort of came off a
little bit we broke 4 000 and rallied
back uh up above uh 40 20 sort of that
key level I talked about yesterday got
all the way up to uh you know 29 and a
half and then you know then sort of went
sideways the rest of the session
um the US numbers came out and you know
spiked up pulled back but then we
continued higher and
sort of made another run up towards
yesterday's high then what happened
Market boom boom boom boom boom sold off
all the way down into the 40s you know
from 40 30 area broke 40 20 all the way
down to you know 39.50 into the 39 40s
so
again I don't want to get into the whole
uh
you know macro views I I'm not a
economist I don't pretend to put myself
out as an economist but you know it is
important to understand
you know when you have numbers or you
know like last night you had the bank of
Japan come out you know in my trading
room or you know my weekly training
sessions for users of my software you
know Daniel pointed out that hey you
know what guys don't forget Bank of
Japan is later tonight and you know it
was an hour later and you saw what
happened in in the Yen Futures right Yen
Futures got spanked
um this is the footprint chart
and you know we were trading around uh
what was that 78 40 78 45 and then we
just uh you know what was interesting is
you know when it sold off there was
quite a bit of volume on both sides of
the market once it sort of got down
um obviously into the new low so it
wasn't like uh you know what we see
generally in the U.S markets where it
just gets swept through and there's very
little counter trade I mean initially
there was but then you could see you
know trading both sides of the market
um as opposed to just all zeros on the
offer side so they were they were you
know there were buyers on the way down I
mean aggressive buyers now partly
you know when when people have stops in
the market just sort of talking a bit
about you know stop runs
because you know I know people like oh
there's a stop running here Etc and and
to be honest you know if you see a stop
run in the market by the time you react
to it it's it's too late you can't
really
um react because the market will move
too fast but
you know a lot of times you like the big
institutional
desks
if they have an order it's a stop order
in you know either the Yen or the
e-minis they don't just put it in there
with no limit they they will put it in
with a limit so oftentimes you're going
to see you know people have put in a big
stop order now I'm not saying this
happen but this would explain why you
see sometimes you know big offers coming
in but in this case you know what we're
seeing is you know if there's a stop you
know say someone's got 100 contracts to
sell you know they put that's you know
we'll call it 7820 you know they'll put
it down to say 78 10 with a you know
with a limit of 7810 so you know stop
with a limit and you know it'll just
sort of work its way down
um so you had to have some good decent
two-way activity here right obviously a
big long bar Market is looking for
liquidity
now
what was interesting about this big bar
down just really quick from just sort of
a price action standpoint is it
continued lower in the next bar
oftentimes you see that big spike down
like this and then it just sort of goes
inside in the next bar and the next bar
the fact that it took out the low in the
next bar to me was you know kind of
bearish in the sense that yeah we're
continuing lower immediately as opposed
to just sort of catching our breath and
then going sideways so it did you know
eventually make new lows down to this
number here 77 even the figure
about what was interesting you know at
such a nice round number
um didn't really trade very much you can
see just 14 contracts traded there
eventually it took it out and you're not
seeing a lot of size you know defending
that area so
it was just one of those things where
you know you tend to expect to see big
bigger volumes than you know you've seen
what's here 14 here 47 so about you know
60 contracts
uh plus we've taken trading on the offer
you know 70 contracts there just wasn't
that big support in the market for it to
really bounce up off of okay even though
you know it did test it again here you
have a Divergence it did take it out
finally started to see some support
coming in here much later but we're
continuing lower but really the sign
you know and and you know this is not an
order flow really thing for me it's more
I'll say price action but it's just when
I see a that big bar sort of take out
the lows right that initially and then
the next bar
goes even lower
it's just telling me there's still more
selling pressure now I said usually
you're going to see the market Spike
down like that and then it go inside for
a series of bars but the fact that it
just sort of came right back and made
new lows
um
was a bit uh it was a bit bearish on the
market all right so let's sort of get
back to the the e-minis here I sort of
diverged there for a second but again
you know e-mini's spiked up right here
when uh you know the bank of Japan right
is very bullish for the market keeping
that monetary policy the same you could
see let's just go back to that time that
was last night
21 o'clock
where are we here
okay
so you can see it's sort of the opposite
right you see the big move up
then you're going inside inside and then
eventually start making those new highs
but usually
you know you get that big reaction move
and then you go inside inside just like
today okay if you remember
all the time was that initial move
there's a couple a couple of nice moves
here right you got the big move up
inside inside you know and once you
start going inside then you're sort of
watching okay what happens when we sort
of break out of you know that initial
bar
right this was the Yen we did it
basically on the next bar
in the e-minis you know went inside
inside then broke up or broke up broke
out to the upside and you know later it
didn't make that high and it broke to
the downside
so
what was interesting I mean there's
again you know you remember if you
remember yesterday
uh was yesterday Tuesday
in the S PS right there was that big
size going through
at 40 20 here right right over here you
know the 4 000 contracts and you know
it's just an area of Interest right so
again when we came into the cash session
today
okay we're trading sort of above that
area cash opened up sort of came down to
it it was kind of uneventful I don't
want to say oh look at that you know it
was rotating around there yeah it was
also rotating around a lot of different
levels
but you're not seeing any big size
really come in here I mean There Was You
know the 1700 that came in here 15
minutes after the cash opened
and I don't know I don't really read too
much into that at this point you know it
they had all that time earlier to to
work it
um I mean they could have sold it up
higher at 27 if they really wanted to
um but the market you know it got up to
you know the 28s it didn't hit
yesterday's high yesterday's high was 35
right up 35 and a quarter so just above
today's high we did eventually go up to
new highs here at 909 now
right off the high the next bar big
negative Delta big strong aggressive
selling right you're seeing one two
three four imbalances coming into the
market
so you couple that with the strong
negative Delta you know the Delta volume
also strong you know you're sort of
leaning towards to the downside now at
this point you know or it's 9 10
everything that's come out up until this
point has been bullish
for stocks starting with the bank of
Japan
right
trying to get short I'm not saying oh
yeah you know this is the the perfect
sign to get short because everything
you're seeing in the market today news
wise even flow-wise up until this bar
has been bullish and I'm not convinced
that even though I got this selling
coming in
the aggressive selling you know with the
imbalances with the Delta with the Delta
volume that hey this move is over oh you
can stick a fork in it or gonna drop you
know another 70 points
so you just gotta watch you know because
even if we did drop you know you're
still sort of the back your eyes in the
back of your mind you still have that 40
20 level
to think about and you know eventually
you know we started going sideways then
we broke down to 40 20. and again you
know we just sort of rotate around there
bounce you know we get through it then
we sort of come back up you know now
we're starting to see some Stacks
selling imbalances come in here here
and then now we're clearly below 40 20.
whoever that seller is at 40 20 he's
looking like a a genius but we're
running into some size down here is 1500
okay here's the 1100 okay so there is
some support in the market but the
market isn't getting through that so
you're seeing
some price levels with
decent volume and by decent volume I
mean over a thousand contracts right
um 1100 okay so there is support and
it's getting through it not only is it
did it get through it here but it got
through it pretty quick right fifteen
hundred and then you got an imbalance
below it another imbalance below it okay
it did come back sort of test that area
just like here it sort of came back it's
testing that area now what was
interesting here right you got the 1500
you got the 1100 even on the offer 1100
starts trading back up a little bit
right it gets back past the stack
selling imbalance
and then you see a big offer coming in
here 11.49
okay so we're right around unchanged or
you know where we opened last night at
4008 and a half
let's start putting it together there's
uh some bids here got taken out a bit
here that got taken out
seller here then we're sort of drifting
back up or right around unchanged and a
big seller comes in right supplies
coming into the market here
11.49 so let's start putting these
pieces together okay
big bids
are getting hit markets trading below it
Market's going lower now a big offer
Supply is coming into the market what do
you think is going to happen now again
you could look at these deltas and these
things are
um
and I'll say off the Richter Scale but
they're quite strong here minus 1330
minus 2500 minus thirteen hundred
it's consistent all right it's not like
you know and when you do get a positive
Delta okay 474 390 400 that's it
but you're seeing minus 770 minus 1300
minus 2500 minus 500 minus 1300 minus
eighteen hundred
it's quite a bit of selling taking place
below this 40 20 area just in this
recent history I'm not going to even
worry about what was happening above 40
20 because really what I'm looking at
right now is just this part this
information so strong selling now I'm
seeing
offers come in here
all right so what do you think
do you think the markets can potentially
rally back up to the highs or do you
think it's probably going to start
selling you know the way the way you got
to view it is it's probably going to
start to sell off and then it does
all right I mean the evidence is clearly
there in the Deltas
in the imbalances
right and even in the volumes right it's
just telling you that it's all slanted
to the selling side
and then we start dropping
down down down remember our low is just
right here at 96 and a quarter
right which we sort of did pretty much
right after the open so to get from 08
down to six and a quarter that's not
necessarily a big move it's like 12
points
right so
and and you know e-minis right we could
do that sometimes we do that in one bar
so it's not a big move into the lows
okay so we hit the low get within rather
a tick of the low 96 and a half bounce
up a little bit okay now as we bounce up
there is some buying coming in because
you know we're off our lows 1500 400 173
that's not a good sign in terms of if
you're looking for this Market to keep
going up all right you want to see
you know 1500 1400 1100 ideally you know
something strong but not like
the aggressive buying is is a third of
what it was the first time and then
again another third of what it was
earlier you know this bar here gives a
little bit of encouragement plus 200 so
it's sort of writing the ship but then
the selling comes back in minus 4.96.
right then so small Deltas minus 36 and
plus 17. I treat those you know when I
get see small Deltas like that
um
36 or 17. I just treat it as neutral
because you know in the S P's 50
contracts is is nothing where it could
easily flip from negative to positive or
positive to negative
then the red bar with the Positive Delta
so let's tell me some supplies coming
into the market and then another bar
with some strong negative Delta minus
749 is closing near our Min Delta 757.
you got to be bearish at this point
forget about ah this Market you know all
that bullish information
this Market is is going to it's going to
turn around now and start rallying right
I mean
the the thing about today's market is
like
if anything
you understand that you know the I don't
know how to say it without sounding
confusing the markets don't always make
sense so don't try to make sense of the
nonsense meaning you know you had all
that bullish information yet the market
is not rallying it's selling off what do
you think is going to happen
now actually you should start getting
into the thought of maybe we're in a
flow driven market right because our
high was at you know whatever it was 32
and then you just seen
repeated selling right in the Deltas you
can see that the imbalances
um then we're coming into the lows right
96 and a quarter well it just takes it
out very easily right you can see you
got one two three four five imbalances
going into the low take it out okay
I'm trading down here at 90 just make
new lows like every every couple of
minutes
and then this work is interesting so
here you have a green candle with
positive Delta right that's a Divergence
right because price is trading up but
Delta is still negative
okay but you know that's not by itself a
reason to get long the next bar New Low
more selling coming in but real again
you know really the the sign
to be getting short was
up here below you know this 08 and a
half area I mean you just see a lot of
bearish information coming in to me this
volume here was sort of like the kiss of
death for this Market this 1149 and just
telling me you know what
this Mark is going further down and then
so we make these new lows
right nullo here with that Divergence
then you got Divergence and Divergence
okay now again you don't have a bullish
ratio okay that's these black numbers
here right if it was a bullish ratio
it'd be a a green number
under the bar
which would tell me that there's bullish
order flow in that bar so it's not just
a normal order flow that's why it's
colored black now
if you do have you know some positive
Deltas in here and it's closing you know
near our
Max Delta which is encouraging 778 286
versus 296 778 against 808.
I don't like that it's sort of reversed
I'd prefer that the 286 came before the
778 but you know obviously it didn't
then this next bar starts trading up 745
positive Delta hey that's great you got
700 positive Delta 745 and in between is
you know close to 300 maybe we can start
building off this and we could bounce
back up above 4000 and make another run
at the highs well
Divergence failed Divergence Divergence
I've talked about this
a bunch of times in the last several
weeks and understanding the type of
Market that you're in
right and a flow driven Market is the
best way to describe a flow driven
Market either to the upside or to the
downside is a market that's driven by
other time frame Traders the the longer
term Traders you know the traders that
have a more
deeper Pockets than you and me and I can
hold through you know positions they're
going to hold positions for a lot longer
okay and they're the ones that move the
markets because they've got the money
behind them
and they got the conviction right we're
just day Traders all we want to do is
jump on the back of what they're doing
and a clear sign of a flow driven Market
is a series of failed divergences in a
short period of time in this case it's
10 19 at 10 26 so about seven minutes
so all you got to do is you just got to
sit here with a cell stop right below
this 80 and three-quarters area right
that's all you got to do because if we
take out this low then it would
basically confirm we're in a flow driven
market and we're on a flow driven Market
take out whatever
other indicators you're using you can
just throw them out the window
and just go along for the ride okay so
what happens we start rallying up a
little bit getting weaker 12 in the
Delta minus 384 minus 34 then bam we
break right through this
80 and three quarters area right there
was some liquidity there at 80 and a
half you see the 1250 the 705 the 800.
so you know you're talking close to 3
000 contracts from 80 and three quarters
down to 80 even
so even if you're working a stop here at
80 and three quarters maybe you're
filled at 80 and a half maybe worse
would be 80 and a quarter
and then just sort of goes sideways on
you
and then another new low
how much heat would you have taken say
you got filled
you know your stop is right below an 83
quarter so you're getting filled down
here 80 and a quarter the only rallies
back up to 81 and a quarter so one point
and this is you know you're short at 80
and a quarters next thing you know a few
minutes later trading in the 70s rallies
back up 80 and a quarter
new lows 73 again a little bit back up
82 and a quarter
again so you it's only got two points
against you here
all right it's just going back and forth
new lows new lows now again I'm not
going to predict that it's going to go
all the way down to you know
you know got all the way down to uh
here's the chart
you know into the 40s here but you know
realistically you you could have got
something decent out of the move from 80
at least 10 points down into 70 and what
was your risk right the worst case it
ever won against it was was two points
all right almost immediately
you could have got down to you know 74
and a quarter so you could have easily
gotten five points out of this
so
you know I'm not saying that yeah you
would have sold it here at 80 and a
quarter and and coverage oh yeah you can
cover it way down here at you know
in the 50s or even down into the 40s
later
um you know that that's a bit uh cheeky
to to sort of claim that some people
will you know but uh
me you know it's just about reading the
order flow and going with the market I I
like to be in and out I don't
necessarily like to hold the trade for
longer sometimes I wish I could hold the
trades longer but um
that's just not how I'm wired so anyway
guys you know flow driven markets
understanding them you know when when
every and more importantly when
everything is telling you it's bullish
but the market is selling off pay
attention to that don't try to fight it
don't be sitting here think oh all the
information that came out is bullish I
gotta buy buy some more buy some more
just like you see these guys with crypto
right with Bitcoin I mean now we're
starting to Rally I mean who knows maybe
it's a legitimate rally maybe it's a a
pump and rug's gonna get pulled out
sooner or later
but you see you know if you read
up until about last year everything
you'd ever see about crypto on on
Twitter or on Facebook it'll all be
bullish nobody was ever bearishing
it's hard to remain bullish when the
market keeps dropping right we're
trading 60 000 and then fifty thousand
and forty thousand at some point you
gotta say you know what
maybe I should uh think about this
differently right Market is going down
despite all the bullish information
maybe I should be looking at signs to be
getting short right and and today the
clearest sign was the divergences that
failed
so anyway guys I hope you enjoyed this
video and I'll see you guys on the next
one bye bye